As we said earlier,
you've probably used PKI on the web.
An example is Google Mail.
This also helps explain the value
of the certificate authority.
We're using Mozilla Firefox here,
but you can,
and should do the same with any browser.
This lock icon,
adjacent to the URL of the website,
indicates that it's secure, using HTTPS.
Clicking on it, as we see here,
indicates the site name www.google.com,
and that the connection is encrypted.
Clicking here,
brings up more information, including
the name of the certificate authority.
In this case, Thawte Consulting.
This would be the entity
that issued the certificate.
You already know that
browser can verify that by
using the certificate
authorities public key.
So browsers are normally shipped with
those keys to use for this purpose.
Remember, it is a public key,
so anyone can have it.
Finally, clicking here,
brings up Google's public key,
showing that it really is public.
The text provides more details about
the key, and their references for
the more technically inclined students,
who want to know even more.